ήθηκα με τημουσική γενήθηκα με το τραγούδι θυμά μετα παιδικά μου χρόνια και εύχομε να
υπάρχουν και τα τεκμύρια γιατί είμαστη κε κάποιες άλλης εποχής ηπάρχουν ακόμα πιτείο κασέτες που
εμε τεσθάρο πετεχρό να ανεπαίνω πά σε μια καρέκλα να σας τραγουδίζω και ξεκινάδω τραουδά
ο δεν θυμαμε πιο τραγουδούσα θέλου ν πηγαίνω να πηγαίνω να πηγαίνω του διονησίου κάτι
τέτοιο και στο στρατώ πάλι στη μουσική βεβαίως να ξωστρατώς ήταν έναστην ψυχή μου ένα
περίεργο πράγμα όπως όλων των παιδιώ εγώ ήδιασχολιώ μου να μετιμουσική ίδεδεκαέξι χρονών όταν με
πήραν από τοχαίρι και μου είπαν υπάρχει ένας διαγωνισμός που λέγεται αφετηρίες καλό είναι να
πας πήπότα δεκά έξι εκίνησα μα θήματα φωνη δικής πιανο κι θα ρα θεωρία και
δέθηκα με τη μουσική όταν ήρθερος στρατός και μου τάκοψε λίγο όλα αυτά με πιασε
λίγομια στεναχώρ για παρόλα αυτά είχα το δυναμισμό το ότι άλλος ένας μικρός πατριώτης απαλέψει
γιατη κύπρο μας και τα λιπ ξι πέρασε ο στρατός από κει επέρα ξεκίνησε το
παιχνίτι που όλοι νομίζω λίγο πολύ αν και θα τα πούμε και μπαίνει στη ζωήσε
όσο περάητων και παίνει στη ζωή μου το ουπεράιο και εκεί θε μαθαίνουν όλοι μα
ξεκινάι το μαγικό ταξίτι θυμάσει από τότε τις πιο ρες στιγμές δηλαδή αν ότς πράγματα
και να κάνω πολύ μεγαλύτερα και να κάνου είναι η αφετηρία μου νομίζω ότι όλοι
έχουμε μέσα στη ξυχή μας μια ιδιαίτερη σκέψηκε αγάπη στη ο ξεκίνημα μας εγώ έμο
να πάρα πολιτηχερός ιμον ένας άνθρωπος από την κύπρο ένα παιδά κι απότην κύπρο που
δεν ήξερα κανέναν στην αρχήήτα και λίγο περίεργο το συνέίστημα γιατί δεν ήξερα και πως
υλιτουργή η τηλεώραση δηλαδή ξεκίνησαν ταείχωγραφεί επιτεογραφή ιστα αλλά εευκετά λιπά πήγαιναν στην αθείνα